hey youtubers it's Charlie a lot of you
guys were asking me to do a video about
the new Iron Man armor so here we go
what I'll do is I'll talk about the new
ultimate Iron Man spider-man armor and
then I'll talk about the evolution of
all of his suits from the first Iron Man
film there are now 46 47 if you include
this new version of the armor but we
don't know the actual designation yet so
there's a new round of the Spider Man
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video if for one of the new Hasbro
figures which is what this is actually
based on this reminds me of that scene
in Civil War where spider-man walks into
his apartment talking to Aunt May not
realizing that Tony Stark is sitting
there just talking about his day say
there's a sick car parked outside what
the hell's going on and then he sees
Tony Stark oh my god
there's a sick new Iron Man car in
spider-man homecoming so who knows when
they're going to reveal it but it
actually looks a little bit like the
ultimate spider-man armor mixed with the
MCU Iron Man armor design in the thing
about the ultimate Iron Man color scheme
is that the movie itself is borrowing a
lot from the ultimate universe the
ultimate spider-man title with the
character like ganky who's actually met
leads in this movie so they're just
borrowing a lot of story character
elements from the Ultimate Universe it
would make sense that they would borrow
a couple visual things - so the Iron Man
armors themselves have changed a little
bit with each movie you know within the
Iron Man franchise itself they change a
lot but just within the Avengers movies
they get tweaked just a little bit every
new movie even with Civil War he gets a
new version of the armor it just there
was so much stuff going on at Civil War
did not as much attention was paid to
the new Iron Man armor as you would
normally see and he wasn't even in the
armor that much Robert Downey jr.
walking around on sets pretty cool -
when you watch him in the behind the
scenes you see that he's one of the few
people that does not walk around in full
costume now they've got it down to a
science so if you watch the old Iron Man
films and you look at the old versions
of the armor it looks very different
because it's practical like it's
actually him standing inside physical
armor filming scenes nowadays they have
it down to the point where Robert Downey
jr. can just walk around on set super
comfortable even if it's super hot in
the Atlanta Sun and just filming scenes
in
add the armor and post-production there
are a number of reasons why Tony Stark
would give himself a new suit of armor
in this new movie the whole thing in
Iron Man 3 was that he was moving past
that but then they explained when they
got the Civil War that he just couldn't
leave a behind like he just couldn't
stop being Tony Stark so for everyone
who was bummed out at the end of that
movie when he threw the arc reactor into
the bay
that was just meant to be a bookend for
Iron Man if Robert Downey jr. didn't
renew his contract there's actually a
funny story about that that I'll tell at
the end him renewing his contract for
these New Avengers films but the way
they colored in this the red and yellow
accents on a grave base it just meant to
accentuate the red red for spider-man so
the color scheme is very appropriate to
the movie in whatever functions he's
added to it probably has something to do
with fighting the Spider Man villains
animal scene villains even though it all
flows from technology we talked a lot
about how Tony Stark Robert Downey jr.
the Iron Man movies are so influential
in the way that they built the MCU you
have mutants over at Fox with the x-men
universe very organic space you have the
older spider-man films with Sony very
organic animal-themed villains you have
the DC abilities people like Superman
having abilities that flow from their
biology then you have the MCU with a lot
of aesthetics a lot of powers flowing
from technology based so now because
Marvel is producing spider-man his
rogues gallery flows from that too so
you have your technology-based vulture
that looks very Tony Stark Chitauri
inspired from the Avengers films so the
whole idea here is that this is a
continuation of the Spider Man Iron Man
story from Civil War Tony Stark is super
bummed out so this is important art for
his character in this film too as well
as Spider Man it's really spider-man's
movie Iron Man is just a guess but you
have to imagine that Iron Man is getting
his own movie broken up into a bunch of
different movies the way the Hulk is
like everybody's heard the story about
how Disney doesn't have the rights to
distribute a whole film so they don't
want to make it if they don't have all
the rights so they're giving Hulk his
own movie just broken up into a bunch of
different pieces between Thor Ragnarok
and Avengers infinity war so because
they have so many other characters to
introduce and Robert Downey jr. is such
an expensive actor
amortize the cost of hiring him over the
course of a couple movies and I totally
love it there's been so much Tony Stark
now it's time to focus on new characters
like spider-man but now they can roll
them out with cool new shiny armor the
way you normally would without having
him completely take over the entire
movie I'm guessing that there's probably
less than 20 25 minutes of Iron Man in
this movie in yes he will probably steal
every scene that he is in it just based
on the trailers it seems like whatever
this new armor is going to be it's not
going to debut till later in the film
because in the trailer one they have
that opening clip with him from Civil
War like they literally just copy and
pasted some of Civil War just to tell
you where things pick up in the film and
then later when he's swinging through
the streets he's actually wearing the
old version of the armor too so it
sounds like that moment with them
swinging around is from earlier in the
film because usually they say big cool
reveals for later in the film like after
he comes to this Avengers base or maybe
after Ironman decides he's finally going
to get up off his ass in help Peter he
keeps telling Peter throughout the film
to this chill out don't worry about
being an adventurer
Peter won't shut up about it I want to
prove myself he keeps treating me like a
kid so there's got to be some big third
act reveal where Iron Man comes in helps
them out and then spider-man Lance the
big win but let's do a rundown of all
the different versions of the Iron Man
armor they don't officially have a
designation for this new armor yet but
starting with mark one in the first
Ironman self you have mark 1 mark 2 and
then mark 3 then an Iron Man 2 you have
the mark for the mark 5 the briefcase
armor the mark 6 was the one that he
used when he fixed the arc reactor with
the new power source and in Avengers it
was the modular armor that would attach
mid-flight using the nanoprobes been in
Iron Man 3 that was where it really got
crazy
you remember that like went way
overboard and obviously was the hat tip
to him destroying all of them at the end
of the sound like I don't need all this
crap so it was mark 8 all the way up to
mark 42 the mark 42 was the armor that
he wore for most of that film the age of
Ultron armor was 43 the 44 was the
Hulkbuster that was one of the best
reveals from that movie Veronica why did
Joss Whedon
name it Veronica this is so great
because once upon a time Bruce loved a
girl named Betty in Veronica is the
opposite of Betty
[Music]
all right everybody stand yeah
Veronica give me in by the end of that
movie there was a really subtle change
the shinier version of the armor it was
the mark 45 it was more powerful but
that was kind of lost because there was
so much stuff happening on screen then
when we get to Civil War it's the mark
46 so even though it's Civil War armor
is obviously very cool it's always cool
to see a new version of the suit I
didn't like the way they colored that
film so much they dulled the red just a
little bit in unless you're watching the
movie on like a really good calibrated
TV the color looks a little off so it
almost looks like this red version of
the toy armor is just returning it to a
deeper shade of red which I totally love
so let me know in the comments what is
your favorite version of the Iron Man
armor it could be from the movies from
the comics from anywhere I feel like
Hulk Buster and the extremis armor is
still the two coolest armors but he's
not going back to extremis any time soon
and because Hulk is fighting Thor
obviously we're not going to see the
Hulk buster for a while either
but because spider-man is visiting Iron
Man at the Avengers facility we might
get a version of this scene here where
he takes them through the new armory it
does Avengers base now in the comics he
does have a mobile version of the armory
Iron Man doesn't walk around with his
suit on all the time but like we saw in
Civil War like he has a watch that turns
into the gauntlet so he does have
stripped-down versions of the armor for
whatever he needs to do but that funny
story about Robert Downey jr. renewing
his contract with Marvel so he read for
a slightly different deal he reads
through both of the Avengers films which
included his time and spider-man
homecoming the Civil War stuff but he
hadn't done that before ,
a couple years ago they wanted to make
this big announcement so if you remember
the big special panels that Marvel did
where they announced Black Panther they
announced Captain America Civil War all
these big movies they announced Benedict
Cumberbatch's Doctor Strange the reason
they did that we found out now is
because they couldn't do it at comic-con
the year before that which i think is
funny Marvel is big enough they have
enough goodwill in the fandom because
they don't need to go to comic-con but
they do anyway which i think is really
cool but in related spider-man Marvel
news a lot of you been asking me about
the story of Sony selling the rights to
their film business in Disney maybe
buying that so that they can get Spider
Man back Marvel doesn't earn money on
the Sony movies they earn money on the
merchandising so when spider-man
homecoming comes out whatever amount of
money that it makes Marvel will not see
a dime from that they'll just get all
the money from this merchandising here
so you can see how they're really
excited to give Tony Stark all these new
toys during the movie so they can sell
them in real life there's a whole bunch
of Marvel Comics news about how they're
returning all the characters to status
quo maybe I'll do a video about that
this weekend there's a whole bunch of
stuff going on so what's going to happen
later tonight is because it's Star Wars
Friday I'll do buy new Star Wars last
jedi video that we'll post in a couple
hours there's a lego batman easter egg
video that i want to post that it'd
probably be saturday morning there's a
billion easter eggs in that movie it was
crazy so congratulations to Ryan berry
you in one of the Spider Man Hasbro
figures it's for a preorder Hasbro
hasn't started selling them yet so
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there was a new round
that started in this video if it doesn't
get too crazy I'll post that new Marvel
video this weekend I'll announce a new
winner while you wait for that you can
click here for new Iron Fist footage and
you can click here for a new guardians
of the galaxy - thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you in the next video